il ya encore six semaines je n'étais
jamais monter à cheval
et maintenant regardez moi je galope je
saute désole stade superga faits
remontent en selle et pour couronner
tout je me frotte à des succès purement
méchant en plus mais peut-être que je
vais un peu trop vite la salut moi c'est
zurich
tous habitent à los angeles mais je
passe mes grandes vacances sur une île
adorable large des côtes de l'angleterre
avec ma mère ma petite soeur et mon
grand père j'espérais avoir enfin un peu
de temps pour moi mais c'est à ce moment
là que je les rencontre
raven ma conduite l'olypique the bright
falls et mésaventures ont vraiment
commencé
je me suis mise à monter à cheval à
résoudre des mystères à me faire des
amis et quelques années je me suis
jamais autant amusé de ma vie et
j'espère que l'été ne finira jamais
nous allons connaître la vérité
salle des fastes ralenti
[Musique]
une chaude et ça va être une supposée
tentative alors qu'est ce que tu attends